a nuestra amiga ardilla le gusta
recolectar bellotas ya que son su
alimento y digamos que cada día ella
puede recolectar tres bellotas y yo me
pregunto cuántas bellotas tendrá si hace
esto durante cinco días una forma de
pensar en esto es que cada día ella
recolecta un grupo de tres bellotas
podemos ver esto como lo que ella
recolecta en un día en el día dos
ella recolecta un segundo grupo de tres
bellotas en el día 3 puede recolectar un
tercer grupo de tres bellotas y es el
mismo número de bellotas que ella
recolecta cada día el cuarto día
recolecta otras tres y el quinto día
otras tres si tienen curiosidad por
saber cuántas bellotas recolectó en
total pueden contarlas una por una o
pueden pensar que ella tiene cinco
grupos de tres bellotas cinco grupos
iguales de tres bellotas podemos decir
que son cinco grupos de tres bellotas
por lo que la cantidad total podemos
verla como 53 es
y podemos ver 53 es como sumar 35 veces
33 333 y si quieren calcular esto pueden
contar los de tres en tres
esto es 36 9 12 y 15 porque si a 3
sumamos 3 a 6 si sumamos otro 3 de 9 si
sumamos otro 3 da 12 y si sumamos otro 3
da 15 esta es una forma de saber que hay
15 bellotas
pero aquí comenzamos a entrar en
contacto con una de las ideas
fundamentales de las matemáticas y de
hecho ya la aplicamos pero no hemos
usado la palabra quiero decir que
estamos multiplicando estamos usando la
multiplicación la multiplicación es la
noción de tener varios grupos iguales de
algo así que una forma de expresar lo
que acabamos de hacer es que cuando
decimos 5 3 es es lo mismo que decir 5 y
ahorita les presento un símbolo nuevo 5
x 3
todas estas cosas son equivalentes ya
están acostumbrados a abrir grupos
iguales múltiples grupos iguales están
acostumbrados a sumar algo múltiples
veces también están acostumbrados a
contar salteado y al hacer esto de
cierta manera ya han hecho algún tipo de
multiplicación cuando alguien dice 5 por
3 pueden verlo como 5 grupos de 3 o
pueden verlo como 5 13 o pueden verlo
como 3 333 3 o lo pueden ver como 15
hasta aquí lo dejamos hay muchas formas
de practicar esto en khan academy y
asegúrense de comprender la idea
principal pero como ven este es uno de
los conceptos más útiles que aprenderán
en toda su vida